[Music]
foreign you are watching The Press
preview her first look at what's on the
front pages as they arrive in the next
half hour we'll see what's making the
headlines with Kezia dugdale the
director of the John Smith Center at the
University of Glasgow and Matthew Lesh
the head of public policy at The
Institute of economic Affairs so let's
see what's on some of those front pages
for you now will be I leads with news of
fresh and more disruptive Mass NHS
strikes in January as it says the health
unions are digging in for a battle with
Downing Street overpay demands
the times carries a plea from Health
officials for people with coughs or
coals to stay away from grandparents as
flu cases rise and add further to the
pressure on the NHS
despite the current economic Misery the
express says that we will have a Merry
Christmas because people are determined
to Splash what's left of their cash over
the next two days
the change of law in Scotland on gender
identification makes the lead for the
guardian which says number 10 is set to
challenge it raising the Specter of a
major constitutional Realm
well that story is also the lead on the
front of tomorrow's daily mail
the telegraph goes with an investigation
into the case of multiple child murderer
who it says was freed to kill after what
it calls appalling blunders by the
probation service
the mirror claims an exclusive with news
that security surrounding the king is to
be reviewed amid fears for his safety
after a series of incidents where eggs
were thrown
the financial times leads with growing
criticism of America's green subsidies
package which many in the EU and now
Britain's International Trade secretary
say is to protectionists and will hit
uk-based makers of electric vehicles and
the like
while the sun has a story about romantic
goings-on backstage at Strictly Come
Dancing
a reminder that by scanning the QR code
you'll see on screen during the program
you can check out the front pages of
tomorrow's newspapers while you watch us
and we are joined tonight by kezi
dugdale and Matthew Lesh welcome to you
both thanks for joining us this evening
let's start with the eye front page and
this uh NHS Mass strikes in January
further strikes that uh the public will
have to to deal with for Kezia
yeah so the front page here leading on
the fact that we now expect there to be
two strikes in January by ambulance
staff we're also expect new dates from
nurses to strike early in the new year
and this is a secure in the eye that
Junior doctors might join them on the
picket line as well and there's some
total of those three actions could lead
us to the most significant strikes in
the nhs's entire history why because
they want rightly in my view a better
pay deal or at the very least for the UK
government to get around to the table
and to talk about pay which so far has
eluded them
yeah so Matthew it does seem that talks
have been um
not forthcoming with with the government
though that they have been asking for
them um they're saying they're leaving
it to the independent pay review but is
that a poor excuse should they be able
to to talk with a very politicians who
who make the ultimate decisions
look I think I think the government's
stuck in a very difficult position here
Young
sters that we have skyrocketing
inflation and low growth which means
everyone pretty much across the public
and private sectors are experiencing are
real terms to climb their income now
public sector workers did do
disappointing well during the pandemic
with respect to job security and some of
the demands we're now hearing I think
are are out of whack to what is viable
for example the nurses making a claim
for IPI inflation plus five percent
that's like a 19 pay rise now the
government says that this would cost
each household something like 500 to
1000 quid extra I think they're worried
if they start opening up the paid
negotiations with one particularly
righteous uh part of the NHS then the
risk is that this will get carried over
to every other negotiation the
government's doing in the public sector
and therefore this all gets out of hand
and and not particularly affordable in
the short run I think what we've just
seen in Scotland which is the Scottish
nurses rejecting an increased paid deal
from from the Scottish government of 7.5
shows that these negotiations are
fraught with difficulty
we read that uh the Tory veteran
according to the eye Ken Clark who
served as health secretary and
Chancellor he says that ministers should
whether the storm and we can't return to
the situation of 40 years ago is that
what you believe ministers are doing
weathering the storm and um really
bracing themselves for growing
unpopularity as we read Kezia
no I think
I think your government needs to realize
that this is a very serious situation
that they do have to get around the
table and start to negotiate around the
issue of P because people do not want to
strike being in mind every time an NHS
worker goes on strike they lose their
pay they have to rely on strike pay this
is absolutely The Last Resort I think
it's a very difficult argument to make
that the one thing nurses had during the
pandemic was job security because so
many people were ill we all these NHS
workers a huge debt of gratitude they
are on low pay they've had and pay
public sector pay fees for the best part
of a decade now inflation is rising and
they deserve a pay rise now of course
any paid negotiations is exactly that
it's a negotiation the nurses go in with
a starting point and their starting
point is very high they want inflation
plus five percent and the UK government
have to go in with their starting point
and they point to the independent peer
review body the kind of arbiter of these
deals in the past the consent around
that process is broken That's What's led
to these strikes the unions want to
negotiate it's going to require the
government to come to the table and at
least talk about how to improve on the
offer and you know Matthew's right to
say that the Scottish government put a
deal on the table and that's now being
rejected but the very fact they were
negotiating on pay means that there was
no strike in Scotland last week because
they were prepared to enter those
negotiations the dispute is by no means
over and not suggesting that for a
second but talking getting around the
table is one way to avert the type of
strike action we're going to see which
is going to bring the NHS Coastal halt
at the turn of the Year Matthew many
commentators are now saying that the
government are probably holding out for
the independent pay review bodies new
session in the in the new year and
that's when real negotiation will will
start do you think that's the likely
outcome
look I think that's a very potential
outcome there's been some discussion
about the government bringing forward
the next pay round so rather than people
getting a kind of back dated paid
mid-year and people will start getting
uh the higher pay from from the next
round in the second quarter of the year
the government's also obviously looking
at laws particularly on the railways for
minimum service requirements changing
some of the requirements about the level
of support you need to call a strike
action I think none of that's
particularly ideal response you know I
think I think people do have a right to
strike uh and and make a claim about
their pay and that that should only be
restricted in very limited circumstances
but at the same time again here we've
got to ask ourselves a few things one
the NHS is receiving record funding um
there's a record number of Staff in the
NHS who obviously consultants and
doctors and nurses and yet the outcomes
we're seeing aren't getting better so
what is what does the government do with
respect to reform in the NHS
um and then secondarily to that if where
are we going to pay for these additional
um uh claims on the public purse are we
talking about higher taxes are we
talking about more debt and higher
interest rates what is the choice that
people who do want to see these pay
Rises across the public sector what
choice are they going to make where is
the money going to come from let's move
on to the guardian and number 10 is
threatening to block a law that would
make Scotland the first part of the UK
to introduce
self-identification for those who want
to legally change gender Kezia takes us
into this story
let's start with the bill first so this
is a huge moment today in the Scottish
Parliament passing the gender
recognition Reform Act it was passed by
a majority of two to one with support
from all five of Scotland's main
political parties it's been an issue
which has been in Scottish political
debates since 2016. it's been around so
long I was labor leader when it was
committed to back in in those years so
many years ago so the legislation passed
today and now people no longer need to
go through a medical process in order to
change gender there's no doubt it's been
a very heated and difficult debate in
Scotland at times the most of the
conservative benches in the Scottish
Parliament were against it and that has
now led to the UK government suggesting
that they might challenge it under the
Scotland act now the section they're
relying on Section 35 would allow them
to challenge the bill if they think it
might adversely affect on an area of law
which is reserved to the UK Parliament
and I think what they mean by that is
quality act they're concerned there
might be something in this bill which
goes against what the equality act it
intends to do now the Scottish
government are saying very firmly and
very clearly that's not the case in fact
they rejected several amendments put
forward by the Scottish conservative
party in the chamber to put the equality
act on the face of the bill in such a
way that it would do exactly what
they're not being accused of doing so
the Scottish government affirming their
view that everything they've passed
today has been the competency of the
Scottish Parliament and they believe the
UK government would challenge this well
because they just don't like it yeah
Westminster have made clear that it
would consider a nuclear option of
blocking the bill going for Royal assent
a move as we've discussed that would
enrage both supporters of reforms and
nationalist Matthew
I think that's absolutely right this in
some respects risks giving a bit of a
free kick to the SMP and to the
nationalists by demonstrating uh the way
in which Westminster is overriding uh
that the Democratic will of the Scottish
people I think a key part of
decentralizing power is the fact you
have to accept this sometimes
um sub-national government's going to
use the powers in ways you don't
necessarily like and and you should be
very wary about interfering with the use
of those Powers ultimately this this
will end up in uh most likely in a court
case it'll be up to judges to decide
which is not a particularly great
outcome either whether or not there's a
contradiction between this bill and the
the gender equalities act now I think
there's a few respects in which the s p
have decided to take a very forthright
position on gender recognition something
that I'm personally quite sympathetic to
but at the same time raises some some
issues related to uh sex offenders able
to take advantage of it to exploit it
and to what extent are there free speech
and people able to disagree with this
more within Scotland pick under the new
hate speech was that Scotland's past so
a few Associated issues here that
probably do raise Syria's policy
questions and need to be dressed but as
has been said using section day five
would be quite a a jackhammer approach
to this so it would be quite an extreme
response because do you agree with all
areas of the the potential law
I do I mean I've always supported it and
I do so I as a feminist and a member of
the LGBT community I've never found any
contradiction between my feminism and my
LGBT rights activism that said that I do
understand why some people are concerned
about it they worry about the intrusion
into women's spaces but what I have been
very confident in having looked at the
detail of the law is that everything the
equality act says about having sex-based
protective spaces is as true to thee and
tomorrow as it was yesterday and indeed
when the equality Act was passed and 10
years ago now it is the case that you
can have trans women in women's prisons
that's been the case since 2004 what
this process does is make it easier for
some people to access gender recognition
certificates and that has led to people
who are against this bill being
concerned about there being vast numbers
of people falsely and seeking to change
gender in order to access women's spaces
now they're very legitimate concerns
there but they're not concerns that have
persuaded me to be against the overall
purpose of this bill I think there are
many safeguards and protections in place
to avoid the circumstances that those
campaigners are most concerned about
Matthew what do you make of the the
provision for uh Scots to apply for a
birth certificate um with their their
new sex within six months and that's
without a gender dysphoria diagnosis so
with no diagnosis at all
look ultimately my mind
um I see this in some respects is giving
people a greater freedom to decide how
they want to be recognized and how they
identify with with respect to to
government services and they have no
issue with requirements uh associated
with as as you've said um applying for
new birth certificate now of course
there's there's Associated issues here
that that are necessary and and needs to
be discussed in terms of access to
Single Sex spaces but I think it's worth
remembering that there are another 14
um jurisdictions that have introduced
gender recognition laws akin to what
Scotland is doing there hasn't been a
massive crisis that they haven't raised
issues that some of the opponents of
this law have been concerned about now
there is a further debate here I think
where some people reject the idea of the
existence of trans people or that they
they say that more or less and the
government shouldn't be giving any
recognition
um unfortunately that's neither that is
not the status quo anywhere in the UK it
is it is possible going through medical
process at the moment to seek
recognition
um so there are people obviously who
have other concerns about trans
um issues but I don't think that
necessarily changes whether or not
um we should be recognizing them in this
particular context Matthew and Kezia
thank you thus far for taking us through
the papers and showing your views we're
going to take a break
coming up warnings to think twice before
visiting grandparents this Christmas
thank you
[Music]
welcome back you're watching the Press
preview still with me Kezia dugdale the
director of the John Smith Center at the
University of Glasgow and Matthew Lesh
the head of public policy at The
Institute of economic Affairs welcome
back to both of you right let's have a
look at the the times and this is a
warning to to stay away from uh
vulnerable grandparents if you've got a
cough or cold over Christmas um probably
easier said than done for for a lot of
people um what'd you make of this cancer
I think a lot of people will see that
headline and go oh no no again we're
being asked to make restrictions in
order to protect the most vulnerable
people in our lives it's not covered
this time though it's the flu and
there's a suggestion in this article
that it flews at the highest level it's
been in five years that it was very much
at a balance because of kovid and it's
coming back with a vengeance now there's
a consequence of that we need to protect
people who are most likely to
um suffer the extreme consequences of
all flu and that's um older people
reminder also in this article and for
anyone who hasn't had they're a free flu
jab yet that they should access it if
you're over 50 you can get that for free
and in fact if you're under 50 you can
get it from a lot of Pharmacists it's
one thing you can do to stop the spread
and also to protect those people you
care about in your life this Christmas
yeah it is difficult Matthew isn't it
because our immunities are down as we
say because of covert and we've been
locked away and wearing masks Etc
um but but now we have to be be mindful
of that
yeah I mean I think I think through just
like we've learned all the Bitcoin would
be living with flu for many many years I
mean I'm personally been uncomfortable
seeing the kind of logic of covert
extended
um out to other areas of Public Health
advice now of course if you are actively
sick maybe it's not a good idea to go
see a utterly and fragile
um older family member but at the same
time life to some extent is all about
risks and trade-offs and whether or not
you therefore don't see your family at
all over Christmas seems like quite a
miserable way to to be spending the
festive season and at the same time of
course I think re-emphasizing the advice
about ensure you do get a flu jab my
partner just recently got the fluid I
was very much loading it over him that I
was symptom-free as a result of my early
flu jab in September so they do they do
seem to work and uh I can say go go and
get them because they're even if you are
a bit younger the flu can be still be a
bit miserable no it can be very very
miserable maybe we we sort of go back or
becomes part of our normal day-to-day
routine to wear masks maybe that will
help I'll just throw that in there but
we don't need to discuss it right now
let's have a look at this last story and
according to the express we are going to
have a merry Christmas if it kills us
we're going to go out and spend our
hard-earned money Kezia
yeah I'm not sure this is so much a
story is a plea for help from the detail
sector that of course had a really
difficult um year and it's a call to
action really with 40 hours to go until
at least the shop shut and Christmas
begins and the truth sense and an appeal
that we all go out and and spend our
money to cheat ourselves up whether that
be on food for Christmas meals or buying
presents in the shops for the people
that we care about and we're going to
spend the weekend with real hope here
that there's going to be a rush at the
retail and kind of exchecker and a boost
to the economy in the dying days of
2022. yeah I like the way the article
says a last minute spending spree will
give High streets a much needed 2.6
billion pound boost as if they know
exactly how much we're going to go out
and spend Matthew
yeah it's it's a very it's very
optimistic and and forward-looking and
positive and and look there's no doubt
uh a lot of truth to it that there is
like there's a cyclical spending pattern
we know that every every year around
this time people do spend a lot more
money they they buy a lot more groceries
uh for for Christmas related events as
well as um
things for for people they they do love
and and presents um of course it's not
not for everyone there's a lot of people
this have you struggle to
um provide the kind of Christmas they
want for their family and that should
kept the back of mine but for those who
do have it you know live life to the
fullest spend uh spend to fulfill your
needs and wants yes consumer expert
Scott Dixon quoted saying cash strapped
consumers are determined to enjoy this
Christmas despite the ongoing chaos with
strikes and the cost of living crisis
after previous years of covered
restrictions so yeah go out and spend if
you can if you can afford to Kezia and
Matthew thank you so much for taking us
through the papers we'll see you in the
next hour